-We're about to play a game
called "Auto-Tune Up."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Auto-Tune Up ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Oh, no, no, no ♪
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Now I'm gonna need some help.
His movie, "The Last Son," is in
select theaters December 10th.
Please welcome Colson Baker,
a.k.a. Machine Gun Kelly!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What's up, Jimmy?
-That's what I'm talking about
right there.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, guys.
-Colson Baker.
All right, bud.
Here's how this works.
We're gonna take turns
hitting this button,
and it will select a random,
boring paragraph --
okay? -- and our job
is to turn it into
an awesome song with the help
of Auto-Tune.
-Good God.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, I'm up first.
Let's see what I'm Auto-Tuning.
Let's start the generator.
[ Beeping ]
"A guide on how to care
for a Christmas tree."
Okay.
-Okay.
-All right, buddy.
Here we go.
Wish me luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Step one --
put the tree in the water ♪
♪ Step two --
you trim the trunk ♪
♪ Avoid cutting it at an angle
or in a V-shape, baby ♪
♪ Step three -- water it daily ♪
♪ Step four -- be cautious
of heat sources ♪
♪ Such as lights
and fireplaces ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ And step five --
enjoy the tree ♪
♪ Enjoy your tree,
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-The deep voice!
Wow.
[ Both imitating a deep voice ]
I broke a sweat
on that one.
Colson, now it's your turn.
-I don't want to go.
[ Laughter ]
-Let's start the generator.
Here we go.
Hit that when you want to stop.
"A Nextdoor post about crows."
You know the app Nextdoor?
This is a post about crows.
And you have to Auto-Tune.
-Okay.
-Just -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh,
ooh-ooh ♪
♪ I need you to stop
feeding the crows bagels ♪
♪ 'Cause they aren't
eating the bagels ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ You are giving them ♪
♪ They are stashing them
in my trees ♪
♪ And it's raining bagels
on my house ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is the stupidest --
-I like that you rhymed
bagels with bagels.
That made me laugh so --
-With their feet.
-You better stop
eating the bagels.
-Those are strong crows
carrying bagels.
-Yeah, they are strong.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's my turn.
Let's see what I'm singing here.
-There's more?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
"The top trending
pet names of 2021."
-Oh, that's great.
-This is helpful, as well.
-That's good.
-Yeah.
So these are top trending --
it's what people
are naming their pets, 2021.
Roots, give me a thing.
-Good luck, buddy.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Joe,
Joe Joe Joe ♪
♪ Joe, Joe
Come here, Joe ♪
♪ If you don't like Joe,
then you can go with Doge ♪
♪ Doge,
Doge, Doge, Doge, Doge ♪
♪ And if you don't like Doge,
this rhyme till you go Mahomes ♪
♪ Doja Cat ♪
♪ Doja Cat now ♪
-That's funny.
♪ Cappuccino, Cappuccino ♪
♪ Baby Yoda ♪
♪ Baby Yoda,
oh, Baby Yoda ♪
♪ Oh-oh, Mahomes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was good.
Doja Cat's funny.
-Doja Cat?
That was the one that got --
Yeah.
My dance move.
You also got up there
and stood like a rock star.
You get out there,
and you were just like --
I was like, "Damn,
that's a real star."
All right,
let's start the generator here.
Come on, Colson.
[ Beeping ]
"A Yelp review of
a body piercing shop in Idaho."
[ Laughter ]
-It feels like it's mine.
-Did you ever make
a Yelp review?
-I feel like I, for sure,
have got my body pierced
in Idaho before.
[ Laughter ]
-You might have.
All right, this hits home.
This hits home.
It's a personal one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ All right, all right,
I got a nose piercing here
♪ Three days ago ♪
♪ Today, the gem in my nose stud
fell out ♪
♪ If I could, they could
change it to a new stud ♪
♪ But the guy, the guy on
the phone was super rude ♪
♪ It's not your fault
your jewelry is crappy ♪
♪ And worst of all, damn,
I got a staph infection ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was amazing.
Give it up for Colson Baker!
We're talking to him
later in the show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ We're talking to Colson
after the break ♪
♪ But first,
Seth Rogen joins us ♪
♪ Come back,
more "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ I wanna talk to you ♪
-♪ Hello ♪
-♪ We're gonna talk ♪
-♪ Talk ♪